i i seems like the safer bet i think in
most cases
um i just realized i was looking at the
stream here and it looks like we were
having a couple of issues with a little
bit of the stream
hopefully i fixed that and so for our
producers behind the scenes i'd love for
them to let me know whether or not we
got that solved but
um in the meantime thank you for
entertaining me with uh with my silly
questions
what i'd like to get into now is kind of
your background um so as people may have
guessed maybe from your name
uh or your accent you grew up in greece
uh and i know you have a you have a
what a master's degree in computer
engineering but i'd love for you to kind
of take me through the journey where
where did you start how did
how did a lot of this go because i know
you kind of got interested early in
conversational ai and and some of this
pattern matching stuff so i'd love
i'd love to understand more about that
yeah
yeah i think my interest in computers
started when
when i was in high school i think i was
around 15 years old
um my best friend was at the time
taking a course in programming outside
of school
and i found it interesting so i started
reading about you know
programming languages uh basic
in particular and it was coincidental
that at the time my uncle was getting
into the trying to use computers in his
business
and he gave me a computer to use at home
so it was an amstrad
cpc 664.
uh that you know it had the one block
basically that had the integrated
keyboard and the
floppy disk drive yeah uh
and that was a springboard for me i mean
i
i learned a lot using that computer i i
spent a lot of time programming various
things games
computer applications i remember also i
had written
a program for organizing recipes
that i had submitted to a magazine um
in greece and related to computer to
computers
um it wasn't featured ultimately in that
in the magazine but you know it was it
was a good exercise for me
yeah that's interesting you know when
when i got into computers early as well
one of the first applications that we
really looked at in my household was
also
management of recipes that's very
interesting to me i think that was one
of the first things that people realize
like they have all these
very specific recipes written down on
note cards and things like that and they
thought well this is a great way to
store this right i can print it i can
easily hand it out to people
yeah yeah i think it's very useful i
mean right now
if i look at how i manage my recipes
today they're basically
you know pieces of paper bundled
together
so so even you know this day i think i
could use something better but but
anyway
uh so yes so that kicked off my interest
in in computers um i
applied to a study at the university
in patras that they had a new program in
computer science at the time
um and i when i got in i started
studying
computer architecture operating systems
i was very interested at the time also
in building computers from different
parts
and and optimizing them for performance
and uh and i think later in
during my studies it was a five-year
program i
i got in um
in touch with more in artificial
intelligence
so there was a course i was taking at
the time on pattern recognition
and i i went to the library and i came
across a
a copy of the byte magazine that was
featuring an
article about natural human computer
interfaces
yeah and so i that's where i
learned first about automatic speech
recognition and speech synthesis
and just to just to give people a little
uh visibility into
how how long you've been thinking about
this when like you said you had that
copy of that magazine when was that
i was 1992 probably oh my god
almost 30 years ago yeah right so wait
stop
did you just say 92 was 30 years ago uh
the 90s were 15 years ago my friend i'm
sorry
okay all right so so you had this
magazine
sorry 1992 this is a long time ago and
you were looking at
a human computer interfaces yeah
so so then you know
i got excited about speech recognition
and the applications especially
uh thinking that it could improve
accessibility to computers
you know for people with disabilities
and more and more generally but better
access to computers
so so that drew me into
taking more courses into artificial
intelligence actually as part of that
pattern recognition course i built a
prototype phone and recognition system
using
uh feed forward neural networks so that
was that was fun
um and uh and then yeah i think
even my master's thesis at that
program at the university of patras was
in ai it was it had to do with theater
improving
um and then i applied to graduate school
in the us
i got excited at northeastern university
nice
and then continue my studies there
but at the time there was no
sponsored research program in ai at
northeastern
at least i wasn't able to get a research
assistantship uh
working on that and it took a while to
find something you know relating to
to ai so i was actually teaching courses
on how to use microsoft word and and
excel and this kind of computer
applications nice
it was interesting um so so
northeastern's in boston right yes
uh i i am absolutely amazed when you
look at mit
and harvard and northeastern and a few
other schools that are right there
i mean that is absolutely a hub for the
kinds of
technology that we're talking about
right i mean i know i know amazon has
some offices there that are specifically
focused on a lot of this technology
um are are you based there now yeah yeah
i'm basing i'm based in boston
i live about 30 miles west of boston and
and you know at the time when i was
starting at northeastern
uh there was an opportunity to work in a
local company that was
actually doing uh research in speech
recognition and
i was very fortunate to come across that
opportunity so
um so that was uh bbn technologies
okay and um i
did while i was doing my graduate
studies at northeastern
i worked for about two years as a
research assistant at bbn
doing research in speech recognition and
that's where i learned most of the
things i know on speech recognition and
speech technology in general
uh i was very you know lucky to work
with
pioneers in the field like john mccool
and richard schwartz
um and also you know bbn was
participating at the time in in
programs that were sponsored by the
government by darpa
specifically and i got to
submit systems that competed with other
participating teams in uh
so-called darpa evaluation so you can
think of them as benchmarks of speech
recognition technology
yeah and so that was another learning
opportunity there very very
uh very good opportunity to learn so
um so worked on speaker adaptation more
specifically
um then in around 2004
uh i also had some opportunity to work
with
rocket prasad who is now the vice
president of
of uh alexa ai at amazon yeah we've had
rohit on here
yeah so so rory and i worked closely on
one of the
systems that we submitted for the darpa
years program
uh it was the real time submission for
speech recognition and we had a lot of
fun
together we always look for
opportunities to work more closely in
the future
but then we work on different teams
different things
at bbn i i was focusing for some time on
statistical machine translation um
then i worked on speaker recognition and
the language recognition
and when rocket moved to amazon i think
it was 2013
uh shortly after that i followed just
you know to
to get that opportunity to work again
closely with him
yeah so for 20 2013 i i joined in
uh in 2016. but at that point alexa had
already been out so you came over in
2013 with all of this knowledge about
conversational ai
and a lot of the research and learning
that you mentioned
but that was way before the first echo
device was available so
what was that early day look like i mean
obviously it had to be very quiet and
kind of hush-hush but
what was the work like yeah so
actually when i joined the team i
before joining i didn't know what that
would work on it was very very secret
project
right um and
the the team was very small initially we
were focusing on
building one device it was the amazon
echo
there was not even you know alexa as a
concept at the time
and so particularly we're focusing on
improving the wake or detection and
speech recognition accuracy on that
device
and that was a very challenging problem
because
we had to deal with far-field speech
meaning that you know it's a
distant speech right so the user might
be
trying to interact the device from
across the room and then you had to deal
with
phenomena like reverberation and
background noise and music
or background speech which is even more
challenging
um and there was no representative
publicly available data
to use for that kind of problem so
we had to work a lot on signal
processing algorithms
on improving robustness of the system
and and we also had to innovate in terms
of uh collecting
uh devising methodology to collect
representative audio data
for building our our models and so that
was very good
if i can dig into that a little bit so
that's interesting you're looking for
data
that is basically you're looking for a
collection of recordings that are using
this kind of
distance sound right where people are
far away from the microphone potentially
um and and you're saying you guys had to
go basically collect that yourselves
what's the process like for something
like that well
in this case you know we had to
basically
try to recruit people who would come in
in a certain place and
interact with a device based on some
guidance that we provide we didn't want
to
give them two strict you know guidance
on what to say
and how to say it so that it's more like
natural speech
and then collect from different devices
in different placements in the room and
so on so
so that's uh the what was amazing about
the process was that you know we
we moved very quickly and that was the
first instance where i saw amazon
in action right being able to take an
idea from a conceptual stage into actual
large-scale project that that uh we
worked on very very rapidly so that was
that was a lot of uh
yeah a learning experience i i would bet
that sounds incredibly interesting to me
i have a i have a side
question for you um out of just
curiosity you mentioned that early on
you were working on
echo and wake ward detection and that
kind of stuff but that alexa wasn't
really a thing yet it wasn't part of the
project that you were working on so if
you were working on weight board
detection were you working on the words
like echo and amazon or were there other
wake words that you had played with
uh yes we had doing all that data
collection
we had different candidates um and echo
and amazon
i think amazon and alexa were the top
two you know candidates at the time so
um we did you know we had user studies
we did things to decide you know which
which one to go with ultimately we
decided with alexa
i think it was it was the right choice
yeah i agree um
but you know that was the way court i
think you know the the concept of
alexa's uh
uh voice service that enabled
uh natural voice interactions across a
range of device
and different device types that
really materialized after we launched
the echo device and we saw the interest
from from the public
and so so after that you know after
we did that i started focusing more on
on other parts of the system
um specifically on natural language
understanding
and that was useful to have that
experience from my previous
work at pvn on machine translation and
other kind of projects so
so on natural language understanding i
i worked more on the problem of
multi-domain understanding so we have
different domains like music
and news and shopping and so on so
trying to
make sure that we are able to understand
customer requests across
a variety of those domains and be able
to scale
functionality that we developed across
those domains
easily and
[Music]
i also worked on more data efficient
learning techniques
in that space so techniques like active
learning
to select the data that is most
impactful for learning purposes
transfer learning to be able to develop
a natural language understanding for new
skills or new functionalities without
requiring a lot of manual data
interesting so can i ask about active
learning that's that's an interesting
concept that i
is not something that i've been
presented with before so is is this the
concept that you have
let's say you have a hundred entries of
in your data and
um you have some engine some machine
learning something that's saying
these 45 are really useful and these 55
aren't is that kind of the concept
yeah it's i think you can imagine if you
have a large corpus of
uh annotated data
you you can probably identify a subset
of that
that is the minimal subset that can
cover
all the different types of phenomena
that are
interested to model and be sufficient to
achieve good performance
so i think the point is that yeah it's
always true that more data is
better but if you are able to identify
what is the most
valuable or impactful data especially if
you are trying if you have a large
amount of data to sample from i think
that's uh
it's very useful so that you don't waste
annotation resources
on data that doesn't you know give you a
lot of value
in terms of modeling
and then the the natural language
understanding stuff that you were
working on did that translate to
translates the wrong word but did you
use that across any other languages
yeah actually we we did and you know of
course initially we started
uh with english but then as we expanded
to other languages it was very useful to
um to use techniques like uh statistical
machine translation
to be able to port
a bootstrap natural language
understanding
for a new language for example if we
wanted to bootstrap for
german we could use english the german
machine translation system
to take the annotated data that we have
in english
and translate it create an initial
corpus for german
and then build our energy model on that
so that we don't have to wait for
new data to to come in and label it and
so on so that was
an accelerant for porting the system to
new languages
got it so in the in the seven years
you've been here um that sounds like
some of the stuff that you worked on
early on what were some of the other
focus areas that you had uh as you were
getting into this yeah there were
actually
i was fortunate again to work on a lot
of interesting problems
so far at amazon so besides natural
language understanding
i spent some time working with the team
on developing our
speaker recognition technology okay
which is now enabling alexa to provide
personalized responses to customers who
have who have
enrolled their voice yeah i see that all
the time when i say play my music
and it it does uh and it knows that it's
me and it's my music library not my
wife's or my children
right that's great yeah and sometimes
you know alexa greets you
with your name if you know if you have a
note right so that's a
it's a small thing you know but it's it
makes the system a bit more natural to
interact with
the the other project i worked on was
more in the direction of self-learning
so trying to basically rather than
relying on manually annotated data for
all our services try to improve the
accuracy of our machine learning models
uh using customer interactions and
feedback
that we extract from from those
interactions um
and you know one particular problem that
was interesting to me in that is how do
you know
whether the customer was satisfied with
an action that
alexa took right what are the signals
that are indicators of
customer satisfaction or dissatisfaction
and how can you use that to
to improve the system um so are you
relying on things like sentiment
analysis for that or
what are the the tools that you use to
think about that
sentiment is one aspect but there's you
know some
easier kind of indicators to identify
for example if alexa
you ask alexa to do something and
provides alexa provides a response
and then you barge in to interrupt the
response and
rephrase your request that can be an
indicator
that maybe you want something else right
and
it's not it doesn't necessarily have to
do with the sentiment but if you can
also
extract the sentiment of the request
then can be additional information to
use
that makes sense cool
so more recently i've been working on
the problem of selecting what is the the
best skill to respond to a customer
request
among thousands of skills that we have
in the system
and so that's a very interesting and
challenging problem because you have to
be able to do that
um with skills that that are overlapping
in functionality
you have to be able to leverage the
context
around the request you know like what
was the device doing at that time
what was the whatever the device
capabilities
what was the preceding customer request
and response from alexa
and use all of that information to find
among the thousands of skills
which one is the most relevant and
they want to provide the best response
to the customer
right i mean it's a good problem to have
right to have thousands and thousands of
skills available
to customers but i imagine that creates
a very difficult problem for you because
now you have to figure out how to serve
the right one at the right time to the
right person
yeah exactly and you know you don't want
the other issues that customers don't
know all of these skills right and so
i mean it would be easier problem if
they could reference them by name
right and they can do that they can say
you know alexa ask
skill name to do something right
but you know if you have hundreds of
thousands of skills customers typically
don't don't know
what's available um or they
they forget to use the the name and so
so we wanted to have a system that
uh is more natural and enables the
customers to
access the functionality they want or
get the information they want without
having to remember
special invocation phrases or or names
right it should be incredibly natural
right though they should be able to say
things the way they want
and if that somehow leads them to a
skill then it should
exactly yeah that's great so um
are there any other um procedures or
methods
methodologies that you guys are
approaching to think about how to better
serve this stuff for
customers yeah i mean the
the the other problem with this with the
fact that there are so many skills is
that
the discover this discoverability right
so basically you know
how do we help customers know what alexa
can do for them what are the skills that
can help with their goals
um and so
besides you know the natural interaction
that i mentioned earlier where you know
customers can just ask for the
functionality and find we find the
relevant skill automatically
the other thing we can do is to
proactively
make recommendations of skills that may
be relevant at the moment
right so maybe if we can infer what is
the customer's latent goal
given the current interaction uh
can we make a suggestion for a follow-up
skill that can that can satisfy that
latent goal for example
if the customer asks alexa
how long it takes to steep t right
uh then maybe they're doing that because
they they wanted to set a timer
so alexa could not just respond with the
time maybe we can say okay yeah it takes
about five minutes to steep t
but also offer proactively um
to set a timer for that duration that
makes sense so you're kind of inferring
what their ultimate
goal is even though that wasn't what
they indicated they just wanted to know
how long you should steep tea
but it's clear if you're asking that
question you probably want to steep some
tea
and because of that offering a timer
that for that amount of time makes a lot
of sense
yeah so so we have a system in place
that
is we're developing to do this um try to
identify those opportunities and
basically based on some
inference of the latent goals of the
customers
and that's also another interesting
opportunity for
learning from customers interactions
because let's say if you make a
suggestion and
it's not a helpful suggestion you can
learn automatically based on the
customer's
interaction to to suppress it in the
future right so that you don't always
surface the same
experience unnecessarily that's clever
that's smart i like that
so i guess the next question is then
like how are you thinking about customer
feedback how do you take that into
account when you
when when they're interacting with all
of these skills
yeah so there are different forms of
feedback and
i guess you know the one that i
mentioned earlier also
is more like implicit so let's say
the customer asks for a request and then
they don't get what they wanted so they
they
interrupt alex's response and they
rephrase the request
so from this pattern of um
you know to to back to back requests
where one may be a reformulation of the
other
we can we can learn to rewrite
certain requests especially if the
second time led to a successful outcome
right so let's say the one example is if
let's say the customer was asking to
play the
abc song and alexa didn't know what it
was
and then the customer or played the
wrong song and then
the customer rephrased the request and
it said play the alphabet song
and that was successful because you know
the customer listened to that song
until it ended then from that sequence
of interactions
especially if it's a pattern that is
common across different customers
alexa can infer to automatically rewrite
the play abc song to play the alphabet
song
but that that's based on a larger number
of interactions right that's not
something that would change based on one
or two
uh because because i would imagine again
being a developer thinking about those
weird edge cases
there's someone that said play the abc
song and alexa wasn't able to do it and
then they said all right so instead play
ac dc right or some
some artist or band uh you wouldn't want
to then map that to the abc song i think
that might
uh be weird but you you based on a much
larger set of data i assume
correct yeah it's an aggregate form of
learning you're trying to
to see you know whether the uh gain more
confidence in the inferred
[Music]
substitution let's say that you that you
get from these interactions
by looking across customers and across
time
very slowly so do you do you find that
this is a this is a valuable process to
think about this kind of learning like
how many this is how many misses does it
help offset later i guess
well i mean it will it so right now this
system
has been in production for over a year
now and it corrects
uh millions of uh errors that result
from
alexa miss hearing or the customer or
for
from customers you know misspeaking the
requests right
uh and so i think we we estimate that
about
16 of the defects
in alexa are corrected automatically
using this technique
wow and and usually it takes just a few
hours to identify
a defect again if it's a common pattern
across customers
sure uh and correct it versus let's say
weeks would take if you had to
use the traditional supervised learning
techniques and i
i think it's safe to assume this based
on the scale we're talking about but
this doesn't require any human inter
intervention right correct yeah this is
fully automatic
that's that's the beauty of it so you
don't have to have a human in the loop
to validate
the system and you know as i mentioned
earlier in the
in the example i gave before about the
proactive recommendations for skills
even in this case if let's say
alexa has learned a substitution that
seems bad based on negative customer
feedback
implicit or explicit then it can
automatically also suppress that
using some bandit algorithms
so so there are again different ways to
automate this
learning on one hand from learning new
kinds of substitutions from the customer
interactions and also
learning you know which ones to suppress
or you know reinforce based on the
again the customer's feedback yeah and i
would imagine things
things trend and change over time do you
write like just the words that people
use and the meanings that they put on
those words
can change over a period of time and so
it's very possible all of a sudden you
start recognizing new patterns new
requests new word
orders um that ultimately lead to these
things and so over
over a small amount of time i would
imagine you're able to start
accommodating things like new slang
words and stuff like that to match
what they're actually requesting yeah i
think that's that's true and
uh there are opportunities also to
to learn more interactively from
customers as well
so yeah agreed no that's that's very
interesting
i i always wonder on machine learning
engines like this um
whether one person has the power to
influence like if they went out of their
way to just repeat a pattern over and
over
um that would mislead them machine
learning or
if a small group of people decided to
try to be effective in that way
i think we probably have some safeguards
in place for those kinds of
mischief as well but i always wonder
about that when i see something that's
completely driven by
uh by ai machine learning to be able to
say well what would it take to influence
that right
uh no no comment needed there it's just
an observation of mine i always wonder
about when i see these these kinds of
algorithms
yeah um so
uh you recently authored a paper for
icast 2021
and uh it's on speech emotion
recognition is that right
yeah that was uh the that was some work
that the team
was working on emotional recognition did
uh it was basically using um
relying on unsupervised pre-training
using
contrastive predictive coding uh
to help build more accurate models for
predicting
emotion all right so tell me more about
that i'd like to i'd like to understand
that better
uh yeah i mean emotion recognition is
useful in general as as an area
for conversational ai uh if you can
think about you know conversational ai
agents
that are successful interacting with
humans i think they need to be
sort of more emotionally aware of having
this so-called
you know artificial emotional
intelligence right so
um in the applications that we discussed
so far
uh you know a conversational agent could
uh use emotional state of the user
to be able to extract information about
their sentiments for example
maybe when they make a request uh are
they for example frustrated
right uh could it be because you know
the agent
uh didn't hear them properly when
they're trying to invoke
in a previous interaction or if let's
say the response that the agent provided
in the previous interaction was not
accurate or relevant maybe that caused
the frustration so
being able to detect that is very useful
uh it's also useful to be able to
reflect that emotion in providing
responses
so for example uh when communicating sad
news
that uh where you know you would expect
a customer to react
with a certain type of negative emotion
it's better to
use appropriate tone um
and especially in the in the field of uh
open domain conversational ai as
the one that we have in the alexa prize
competition where we have the social
bots that
uh university teams are developing and
for that program uh you
i mean i can't imagine that you have uh
you can have an engaging conversation
with a social bot
for 20 minutes or more if the social
world doesn't have that ability to
understand
emotion and reflect it properly okay
we actually have a question from the
audience if you don't mind um it's about
the alexa answers website uh they said
they spend
some time each week on alexa answers and
they wondered what the metal learning is
on patterns of questions
kicked over to answers like what i guess
what are the mechanisms that make a
question
land over at the alexa answers website
and
how do we how do we measure or manage
the patterns of answers that we see
there
i think the maybe you know the
i think the there are lots of the
problem with question answering is that
there is
a very long tale of questions
and it may not be you know feasible for
a system to
to know the answer to all the questions
right so so the idea
behind alex answers is how do you enable
customers to receive answers to their
questions
um you know
at some time you know like basically you
know
even if let's say the first time alexa
doesn't have the answer
can it automatically do something to
make sure that the answer to the
customer's question is collected and
surfaced
at the later time right so uh so
so that's basically a detection pattern
trying to figure out
what are the questions that were not
that we don't didn't have answers for or
that we didn't have answers that were
satisfying to customers
we have a mechanism for example to ask
for customer feedback you know we
you may have noticed alexa sometimes
asking you know did that answer your
question
right and based on that feedback alexa
can know
which responses were satisfying or not
um and then use that data over time to
identify what are the areas of
opportunity and where you know some
um human in the loop could be able to
provide
answers to cover that space better very
cool
all right so i apologize i thought that
was an interesting question that i
wanted to drop in there but
we were talking about you know the uh
measuring emotional reaction
uh and that kind of stuff what are some
of the bigger challenges you find with
uh measuring you know customers
emotional reaction responses
i think the problem in general with this
space is that
there isn't a lot of representative
labeled data with emotion and so
again you know you need to innovate
in terms of developing algorithms that
can
learn from unlabeled data as much as
possible and the highcast paper is one
example of
an approach that does that right
so the other the other challenge there
is to do
with even if you have let's say lots of
uh
resources to label data uh leveling
emotion is kind of subjective um
and it's also not a very scalable or may
not be feasible for
customer privacy reasons so
so that's where again relying more on
self-learning techniques i think is
important
being able to again learn from
online customer interactions and back
propagate those learnings to all the
underlying components including the
emotional recognition
uh to optimize that over time
all right so specifically around this
emotion recognition we have a couple of
more questions
um that i'd like to ask the first one is
about um
how well they say that they're
fascinated by speech emotion recognition
and they said they think there's a long
way to go with like witty answers and
sarcasm
uh can you talk about that a little bit
because i would imagine detecting
sarcasm is hard it's hard for humans
so i would imagine it's probably
difficult for computers as well
yeah i don't i don't think we are there
yet i mean this is this is very
very challenging problem um
and uh i think you know right now the
technology is more basic
stages where you know you can detect uh
with the call like activation uh like
you know what
what is the the intense intensity in the
in the
emotion and uh valence you know is it
like a positive sentiment or negative
right and
there may be gradations in between so to
go from that to something more like say
you know esoteric like the
sarcasm and wait i think we have a long
way to get there
sure do you do you think that there's a
pathway there though like that's
something that certainly is possible
it's just a matter of
having the right training data or being
able to identify patterns that maybe we
don't yet
think it's possible i mean again you
know if humans can do it
i would expect machines that in the
future with
more you know elaborate training and
better algorithms to be able to do it as
well
but uh but yeah it's it's one of the
areas of
um sort of the holy grail in artificial
intelligence to be able to
uh understand a
human behavior and human emotions
at a very high degree including you know
sarcasm as you imagine
right that uh that always seemed to me
to be a very challenging problem sarcasm
so you said something there though that
was really interesting to me which is
if a human can do it i expect a computer
will be able to do it eventually
uh that's a that's a powerful statement
that's not something that i've ever
really considered
was a position someone would take
because i think that there are an
infinitely large hard number of problems
that humans can do
without any effort at all um but i i
like
i like the deliberate confidence that
you have that
we can solve these problems it may take
time but
we can do it that's uh that's almost
really refreshing to me to hear
because it to me again not being a
machine learning expert by any means
um i dabble uh it's
it's incredibly encouraging to me to
think that
someone that you know as educated and as
experienced as you is willing to say
like yeah we'll get there it'll just
take time it takes data it takes
algorithms but we can do it
i love that yeah i mean you know that's
why i work in this field i mean if i
if i don't have that kind of television
that's true
that's true that's true uh okay so
you're
you're almost eight years into your
tenure at alexa
and you've obviously seen a lot of
what's going on here
what do you think are the things that
have free at least for you have changed
the most since the
since the early days yeah
uh it's quite you know different
actually in the early days
um we used to focus on more foundational
things like we were building one device
as we said the amazon echo
it had a small number of skills that we
developed internally
and we're trying to make sure the device
worked well
around those skills and from foremost
users so the main challenge there was
getting the
the right type of data and learning from
it quickly
whereas now we have alexa
enabled in many languages
lots more customers and data that we can
get
through a lot of different types of
devices developed internally and
externally
yeah there are thousands hundreds of
thousands of skills
so it's a much much bigger space
and now the challenge is more on
scaling our processes you know and
systems and being able to
to learn automatically without relying
as much on manual annotation as we said
earlier you know trying to work
more learning directly from customers
and also being able to enable in
self-service
manner enable our partners
and developers to build new devices
and develop you know highly accurate
experiences for customers to interact
with
with low cycle time and high throughput
um
so the other the other sort of
difference
between you know back then and now is is
our
team has grown in size also right alexa
is a much bigger
organization and it used to be it's uh
sometimes more challenging to
uh to know what its team is working on
within alexa right
so so how do you communicate effectively
keep in touch with all the work on the
ground and
avoid you know redundant work as much as
possible
and how do you how do you enable these
new disruptive ideas to happen
in production when you have customers
who rely on alexa delivering a
consistent robust experience right so
that's another kind of challenge
right no agreed um it's it's one of
those things where once you have your
software in the world
you have to be able to continue to
maintain and run that but also try to
advance it
often say it's you know you're you're
changing the tire on the car while
you're driving it
yeah yeah that's that's hard uh all
right so one of the things is
as we head towards the end of this
interview which by the way this has been
fantastic spiros thank you for joining
me today
um i like to talk about the future and
one of the things that i'd like to get
your thoughts on are
when you think about the field of
conversational ai where do you
personally see it headed
and what are you most excited about
yeah i mean it's uh there's a lot of
interesting trends
in the field and some of the most
exciting things
of course have to do with nowadays we
have this large
pre-trained models that
can help the system learn new tasks with
very little data
often we refer to this as few shot
learning or
zero-shot learning right so you've
trained the system on lots of
data um without explicit labels many
times that's the unsupervised
pre-training
and then you present a new task with
maybe one or a few
a handful of examples and you're good to
go you know that now the system can do a
new task so that's that's one exciting
area i think it's
it's a fantastic opportunity and
continuing
that research is very important the
other
areas i can think of is you know one has
to do with
multi-modal experiences so being able to
fuse information from different types of
uh sensors and
modalities like you know audio visual
touch
to create more immersive natural
experiences with customers
and we have some work that we are doing
on what we call natural turn taking
which enables customers to interact with
the system without
having to speak the way court all the
time right so just you know
you can imagine alexa being able to not
only hear
the customers but also see what they're
doing whether they're looking at the
screen
to to sort of assess the
device directedness in in their
interaction
can provide these more natural
interactions in the future
um another one is we talked a lot about
self-learning
earlier um as part of that
i think you know having more interactive
kind of
teaching with customers is very
important to to enable that and we have
some effort in in that space
where customers can uh actually teach
alexa new concepts
right so for example you know customer
could say
alexa the living room
light to study mode right and alexa
could ask okay
uh what do you mean by study mode can
you teach me
and then you can say well it's 60
brightness
and from there now if you if you
reference that study mode or similar
expression
alexa can recall that setting uh for you
without having to explain it again so
so again that space i think this is a
small example but i think it illustrates
a bigger space of opportunity where you
know this kind of interactive teaching
can can take place
across customers too
and then the last one is there is a lot
of
improvement in computing hardware and
that has enabled
some on the edge machine learning
applications so i think that's also an
interesting trend
especially in terms of lowering latency
and enabling
preserving machine learning got it
very very good so a little a little
backstory on me because you and i have
really never
had much opportunity to speak before
this interview um i
i graduated with a degree in psychology
and then found my way into the world of
computer science
and looking back i feel like a lot of
the things that i have an opportunity to
interview people about here
machine learning ai uh computer learning
all of this stuff
is uh just so remarkably interesting to
me that i wish
i wish it had passed in front of my face
when i was in college because i think i
would have instantly gravitated towards
this
um but i live in the world that i am now
so for for those of the p
those people that are watching this or
that are interested in potentially
joining the alexa team maybe there's
scientists already somewhere else
um you've had a good career seven seven
eight years already at amazon
um what do you do when you're looking
for new researchers for your team
yeah it's a good question i mean there
is
uh a few attributes i look for
when when recruiting people so um
one thing is uh i like people who are
problem solvers
and being able to think on their feet
and
they can take a new problem and propose
a solution to it even you know taking a
problem that has a solution and try to
simplify that
solution so that's that's problem
solving skill is important
um and aligns with our invent and
simplify
uh leadership principle at amazon amazon
we we have 14 leadership
principles that are relevant and guide
our work day-to-day
the other one another attribute is
what you call the builder mentality
right so being able to
not only be strong on the theory but
also on the practice
and have enough knowledge about you know
computers and how computers operate to
be able to
uh quickly optimize your algorithms and
i find that it's very
helpful besides machine learning to have
some background in computer science
especially the analysis of algorithms
computer architecture software design
helps quite a bit uh other is you know
being able to dive deep i i like people
who
have what i call a data obsession
that are not afraid to you know spend
hours looking at the data trying to
sort of find a needle in a haystack
and what else important it's important
to have good communication
skills especially at amazon because we i
use written documents to communicate
ideas and also to
to share progress updates with teams
so that's that's very important um
and uh and finally you know the the
other aspect that i like in in
people you know who are recruited is um
sort of insistence on higher standards
especially in terms of
having the right bass lines to to run
their experiments and compare with so
often it's not good to have a good idea
and implement it and you know
run experiments with it but also making
sure that you compare to the right
standard
right so take the best available
baseline of the time
evaluate against that and then analyze
the results to make sure you have the
right conclusions and the right
opportunity to to go after
being a good scientist right i like that
uh that's uh
that's very good all right well spirus i
want to thank you so much for joining us
today i know
um in addition to the paper that we
mentioned earlier from icasp uh you also
have published a number of other papers
and blog posts
uh and all that stuff can be found at
amazon.science which is uh our science
website
uh and i know that we're sharing a few
of the links here in the chat so if any
of you would like to be able to check
some of that stuff out
uh if you missed any of the links i
think we'll also provide a link to
amazon.science here in just a moment
but feel free to visit the website and
learn more about the science that drives
alexa as well as
a lot of the other research and
initiatives that we're working on at
amazon
uh so spearos i again i want to thank
you so much for being here today
i learned a lot from you and i hope our
audience uh our audience
had an opportunity to uh learn a few
things from you as well thank you
i enjoy the conversation certainly
certainly um so again thank you guys all
uh for tuning in uh you can find spiros
and the rest of the amazon science team
at amazon.science
and with that as we sign off i'm going
to leave you with a short video about
what it's like to work at amazon
science thank you guys all for tuning in
we'll see you again next week
one of the things that i love about
working for amazon as a data scientist
i get time to research ideas come up
with proposals
develop solutions and really innovate in
my role
hi there my name is kalen lee i am a
data science manager in amazon i lead a
team of business intelligence engineers
data engineers and data scientists and
we provide
scientific and analytical solutions to
serve alexa music initiatives
my name is constantinos papianes i'm an
applied scientist and i've worked
in the alexa hml team for almost two
years now
my name is jinding i'm a proud scientist
in amazon now i'm in prime media finance
team my name is patrick
i'm a data scientist in amazon's
networking team based here in sydney
my name is julian pachon and i am the
director and chief scientist for amazon
last month
scientists and amazon owners the fun
part of my job
is to turn data driven evidence into
business decision making
we love trying out new ideas for example
this could be a new way of slicing the
data it could be a new tool to process
the data it could be another methodology
for comparison purposes
or just a whole new business problems to
solve customer obsession
help us make sure we're focusing on
actual customer needs
things that customers would use in their
day-to-day lives and that would
make their lives better we're not
leaving you to the problem we want the
project to solve
we also think about how these projects
can benefit
other amazon team or the open source
community
as a science team the principle that i
value the most
is invent and simplify you know our job
is to innovate we need to constantly
look for new ways of how to do things
and so we experiment a lot in the
experimentation we also
fail a lot and but we aim to fail fast
and when we do that
then we drive innovation